>> YOU'RE NOT A CONTENDER.
>> YES, THEY ARE.
>> THE CAVALIERS ARE NOT
CONTENDERS.
>> THEY'RE IN THE SIX SPOT.
THEY'RE WINNING.
>> SO, CHUCK, WHAT DID YOU SAY
ABOUT THE NETS BEFORE THE GAME?
WHAT WAS YOUR HOPE IN TERMS OF
KYRIE IRVING?
>> I THINK THAT HE HAS TO REALLY
CONSIDER GETTING A VACCINE.
BECAUSE KEVIN IS OUT A MONTH.
MINIMUM.
THEY SAID FOUR TO SIX WEEKS.
IF WE'RE REALISTIC, IT'S A
MONTH.
HE IS ONLY PLAYING ROAD GAMES.
THEY COULD -- HOW MANY GAMES
THEY PLAY IN THE NEXT --
>> 11 OUT OF 14 ON THE ROAD.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER HOME OR
ROAD.
THEY COULD LOSE -- THEY COULD BE
DEEP TO SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO WIN A LOT
OF GAMES WITHOUT KEVIN.
THEY'RE NOT A GOOD TEAM.
THAT'S, YOU KNOW, ALL THREE OF
THOSE GUYS HAVE TO DO SO MUCH OF
THE HEAVY LIFTING.
THEY DON'T HAVE -- THEY'RE NOT
GOOD REBOUNDING.
THEY'RE NOT GOOD DEFENSIVELY.
THEY CAN LOSE A LOT OF GAMES
WITH KYRIE AND JAMES HARDEN ON
THE COURT.
>> THE REASON I ASK THE
QUESTION, BECAUSE I DO REMEMBER
WHAT YOU SAID, WAS BECAUSE KYRIE
ADDRESSED THAT AFTER THE GAME
TONIGHT.
AND WHAT DO WE HAVE?
>> KYRIE IRVING SAYS THE NETS
INJURY SITUATION WON'T CHANGE
HIS VACCINATION STATUS.
I'VE MADE MY DECISION ALREADY.
I'M STANDING ON IT.
>> WELL, THAT'S WHY I HAVE A
TITLE FOR MY BOOK I'M WRITING
ABOUT HIM.
>> I MEAN --
>> NO.
>> BUT WHY YOU WOULD THINK -- MY
QUESTION IS THIS THOUGH.
WHY WOULD YOU THINK THAT A MONTH
OF, LIKE, WINNING AR LOSING IS
GOING TO CHANGE THE DECISION?
THAT'S SOMETHING HE -- I MEAN,
LIKE, HE MADE THAT DECISION WHEN
THEY HAD A CHANCE -- HE IS LIKE
WE HAVE A CHANCE TO WIN IT ALL.
AND THAT'S AT THE BEGINNING.
SO WHY WOULD HE CHANGE?
I WOULDN'T EXPECT HIM TO CHANGE.
>> MAYBE YOU DON'T EXPECT HIM
TO.
YOU HOPE.
JUST LIKE --
>> I WOULD HOPE HE WOULD CHANGE
HIS MIND.
>> AS A SELFISH BASKETBALL FAN,
WOULD I LIKE HIM TO CHANGE?
YES.
>> IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
BEING A BASKETBALL FAN.
>> I'M NOT SAYING THAT HE'S --
LISTEN.
I'M NOT GIVING HIS VACCINATION
STANCE, YES, DO I HAVE EMPATHY
FOR WHAT HE IS SAYING AND WHY HE
IS SAYING?
YES.
DO I HAVE SYMPATHY?
NO.
I REALIZE NOW THAT THE VACCINE
IS REALLY -- IT'S A GREAT SEAT
BELT.
IT HELPS US ALL STAY ALONG ALIVE
LONGER.
WE REALIZE THAT.
WE REALIZE WE CAN STILL SPREAD
THE VIRUS.
SO I UNDERSTAND AND EMPATHY FOR
HIS RELUCTANCY.
I LET HIM TAKE A STANCE.
I WOULDN'T EXPECT HIM TO CHANGE
IT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE SEASON,
NO.
>> THIS THING OF US ONE DOESN'T
LAST FOREVER.
IT'S ALL ABOUT SACRIFICE.
I HEAR THE CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
I SACRIFICED.
I DON'T WANT Y'ALL TO GET SICK.
I DON'T WANT MY MOMMA TO GET
SICK.
I DON'T WANT MY BOYS TO GET
I SACRIFICE FOR THE TEAM.
THE BIG THREE WAS PUT TOGETHER
TO WIN CHAMPIONSHIPS.
WHO KNOWS WHAT CAN HAPPEN NEXT
YEAR.
WHO KNOWS WHAT CAN HAPPEN THE
YEAR AFTER THAT.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT CHANCE,
KENNY, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU GOT
THAT SLOT, YOU HAVE TO GO FOR
IT.
>> HIS STANCE IS NOT GOING TO
CHANGE.
>> NO.
I'M NOT SAYING --
>> I'M NOT SAYING IT'S RIGHT OR
WRONG.
I'M SAYING WHAT EVERYONE IS
THINKING.
LIKE, HEY, WAIT.
YOU SACRIFICE WHAT?
YOU STILL COULD PASS THE VIRUS.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING
WHO ARE NOT TAKING IT.
I'M JUST SAYING I'M GOING TO DO
IT BECAUSE I FELT IT WAS GOOD
FOR ME.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO PROTECT ME
BETTER.
AND THAT'S ALL I CAN DO.
>> I DON'T CARE WHAT IT IS.
I'M JUST SAYING IN THIS THING OF
OURS, WHEN YOU WANT TO WIN FOR
YOUR FELLOWS AND, YOU NOI,
EVERYBODY ELSE IS DOING IT,
SACRIFICE.
THAT SAY IMPORTANT ROLE.
>> YEAH.
AND I ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW, HE
TALKED KEVIN DURANT INTO GOING
TO BROOKLYN.
HE TALKED HIM INTO GOING.
>> THAT IS BEFORE COVID-19, BRO.
>> NO.
>> YOU CAN'T SAY THAT.
>> NO, BUT I'M SAYING IF YOU --
IF I SAY, KENNY, LET'S GO TO
ANOTHER NETWORK TOGETHER.
AND THEN I SAY, HEY, KENNY, YOU
SIGNED YOUR DEAL.
AND I CHANGED.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK I'M GOING TO STAY AT
TURNER.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS FAIR.
LISTEN, I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THIS DUDE
ANYMORE.
WHETHER THEY -- I JUST H